hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and Alyssa and
I'm dan cyber today we're going to be
watching the trailer the game trailer
for uncharted 4 is there a subtitle F ah
thieves end question mark really riddle
question for you guys do you think
nathan fillion should play Drake in the
movie I do they didn't fill the on yes
filly on you'll really appreciate
affiliate but I don't even hear ya
Nathan Lane shablam actually yes I like
to in charted actually I think it's a
lot of fun I've never actually beat any
of the games but every time I'm playing
it I think it's really [ __ ] awesome
it's cool story too so yeah I'm excited
watch this trailer
let's check this [ __ ] out man do it Oh
you know I am increasingly impressed
with Sony no Louis they knocked it out
of the park is here
I like Naughty Dog how do you remember
Crash Bandicoot do you - oh wow is that
water effect and that boy not take that
face I've seen too many faces flies next
gen flies are the best Zoe I know the
risks one thing I learned and all these
years it's there's no such thing as a
sure fire
god damn dude also by the way huge [ __ ]
yeah
so real
last time
let's go one last time
it's supposed to be the last game I it's
unclear
Wow whoa yeah
yeah I was wrong about the question mark
you that game looks [ __ ] awesome now
like these games with their stories are
incredible dude I'm a total movie buff
obviously know so I'm a big movie buff
and then you play games and it's like
the games like this are like being part
of a movie you know like it's an
interactive movie yeah exactly
who would have thought that Uncharted
series graphic wise at least on the
PlayStation 3 was already impressive and
it's crazy to see you've improved even
that much oh yeah you couldn't really
see it just watching it but I saw still
later and you can see the veins in his
arms I noticed that when I was watching
this trailer yeah it's like the the
incredible amount of you look like they
just took a human and put some filter on
em or something it's like a blur mm a
little more rounded it's super exciting
but the big question is is it really the
end of Uncharted I don't think so mm-hmm
I don't think it's good and on a part
for no well it's it's also money yeah
yeah but I think it's more about
anything on a part for I don't end I
don't end on a for all right
whatever you do Naughty Dog listen to us
just own it on a board just sounds weird
Lethal Weapon franchise ended on a fork
look where that went
Mel Gibson's career went downhill right
after that and that was a reason why
it's a curse nothing to do in the Jews
out of all of this entire III like it
was only confirmed that my decision with
going ps4 is the best route was like
okay ELISA please let me know what's up
just sayin
mmm-hmm there are a lot of really great
games that you have to play not even a
question of should you record you but
you have to play that are not available
on the ps4 not saying that you should
get one just say you should have one of
each
yes actually that's the best way to do
it yeah I mean that's that's how I'm
approaching it I'm going on getting a
PlayStation 4 and then I'm getting a Wii
U because I'm gonna get an Xbox anyway
guys are four new to the channel
subscribe see that I flicked the button
with the button also if you click right
here at this annotation that Brian is
gonna be so generous to put in you can
catch my e3 coverage and all of its
wonderful glory letting you know what
you should know about these conferences
and if you just Lovell this off
subscribe to Alyssa's channel on that
side right here right here you know you
should click it
click this there you go life just got a
lot better for every and her subscriber
count' Skyrim I TAS devil could I get a
shout out if you do could you tell me
what video is voice um it's a shout out
watch them and you'll know it's kind of
the point doesn't they can learn to find
you now that's as we are getting in the
car now and we're coming to you baked
cookies we're gonna be hungry hopefully
you caught this video buddy shout out to
you shout out I'll make a mental note to
find you later
I'll do a video but telling you that
much about a cat's devil conman Inc
shoutout pls would be awesome
well dude awesomeness has just been
accomplished cuz you just got your shout
out car many oh you're an interactive
user man we we talk a lot you're awesome
dude you are awesome
Ernie are you jawing during con man
shoutout I could have sworn I heard you
yawn what Oh something along the lines
of that no I didn't yawn if I did I
didn't even know I did
weird but I like your name the chosen Z
I want to shout out I've subscribed
since when you did the amazing
spider-man 2 review dude you've been
subscribed for a while since May 10
months you knew it yeah first week amaze
yeah dude
yeah that's a good review - one of my
best oh you know often people say what
was your what was your favorite video
Ryan and often I I do reference back to
the amazing spider-man 2 review and my
review of transcendence when I was a boy
I used to imagine what it might be like
to have my own trailer reaction show one
day and I tell you it is exactly what I
pictured it as dick jokes boobs ass Dan
and Elissa exactly what I wanted it to
be anyway what are you guys yeah don't
be in a sexy cat right do you love me
yet hey Justin Z happy birthday or
something